vient la sagesse, n'est pas vrai.
Avec l'âge vient la respectabilité
et des vérités inconfortables.
Mais ce qui était vrai, c'était que mes parents,
l'avaient accepté
et ne faisait pas confiance à l’État pour mon éducation.
Donc, ils ont décidé
de m'envoyer dans une école privée, mais mon père
C'est difficile de financer une école privée
et de nourrir son armée d'enfants.
Je me souviens aller à l'école
pour l'examen d'entrée, et mon père disait
au prêtre - c'était une école catholique -
qu'il voulait une meilleure « héducation » pour son fils,
mais qu'aussi, lui, mon père,
n'avait jamais passé d'examens,
n'avait jamais tenté des examens d'entrée.
Mais pour pouvoir payer mon éducation,
il allait devoir faire des choses louches,
en échangeant des biens illicites
à l'arrière de sa voiture et c'était
encore plus délicat puisque mon père,
d'ailleurs, ce n'est pas sa voiture.
Mon père rêvait d'une voiture comme ça,
mais il avait une Mini cabossée,
et étant un Jamaïcain, il n'avait jamais eu de permis
ni d'assurance, ni de vignette automobile,
ni fait de contrôle technique.
Il disait : « Je sais conduire, je n'ai pas besoin
de validation de l’État. »
Mais ça devenait délicat quand la police nous arrêtait
et ça arrivait souvent, j'étais impressionné par
le comportement de mon père
avec le policier qui montait tout de suite en grade
et P.C. Bloggs devenait Inspecteur Bloggs
pendant la conversation et nous laisser partir gaiement.
Mon père utilisait ce que nous appelons en Jamaïque
la technique de faire l'idiot pour s'en sortir.
Mais ça confirmait aussi quelque chose
qu'il se sentait inférieur
ou dévalorisé par le policier,
perçu par un l'enfant de 10 ans que j'étais,
c'était aussi une attitude ambiguë par rapport à l'autorité.
D'un côté, il se moquait de l'autorité
et de l'autre, il lui portait du respect
et les Caribéen obéissaient
aux autorités au pied de la lettre,
ce qui est très étrange
parce que les migrants sont des gens courageux.
Ils quittent leur patrie.
Mes parents ont quitté la Jamaïque et ont parcouru 6 440 km,
et pourtant le voyage les avaient fragilisés.
Ils étaient timides,
et à un moment donné, l'ordre naturel
des choses s'est inversé.
Les enfants sont devenus les parents pour les parents.
Les Caribéens arrivaient avec un plan de 5 ans :
travailler, gagner de l'argent, puis rentrer.
Mais les 5 ans devinrent 10, puis 15
et avant de réaliser, tu changes le papier-peint
et c'est quand tu sais que tu vas rester.
Bien que ça reste toujours temporaire, pour nos parents,
nous, enfants, savions que le jeu avait pris fin.
Je pense qu'ils avaient l'impression
qu'ils ne pourraient pas continuer avec les idéaux
de la vie qu'ils attendaient.
La réalité était autre.
Et aussi, c'était la vraie réalité
d'essayer de m'éduquer.
Ayant commencé le processus, mon père ne continua pas.
Il a laissé ma mère m'éduquer,
et comme dirait George Lamming,
ce fut ma mère qui fut mon père.
Malgré son absence, ce vieux mantra restait :
Tu es observé.
Mais des observations aussi ardentes peuvent mener à de l'anxiété,
si bien que des années après, quand j'examinais
pourquoi tellement de jeunes hommes noirs
étaient diagnostiqués schizophrènes, 6 fois plus que ce qu'ils devraient être,
je n'étais pas surpris d'entendre le psychiatre dire :
« Les Noirs sont scolarisés dans la paranoïa. »
Et je me demande ce que Bageye en dirait.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai aussi un fils de 10 ans,
et j'ai tourné mon attention vers Bageye,
je suis parti à sa recherche.
Il était de retour à Luton, il avait 82 ans maintenant,
et je ne l'avais pas vu durant 30 étranges années,
et quand il ouvrit la porte,
je vis ce petit homme avec des yeux chatoyants et souriants,
il sourit, et je ne l'avais jamais vu sourire.
Je fus très déconcerté par ça.
Mais nous nous assîmes et il avait un ami caribéen avec lui,
parlant de quelques conversations d'avant,
et mon père me regardait,
il me regardait comme si j'allais
miraculeusement disparaître comme j'étais apparu.
Puis il se tourna vers son ami et il dit :
« Ce garçon et moi avons une connexion profonde, profonde,
une connexion profonde, profonde. »
Je ne l'avais jamais sentie.
S'il y avait un pouls, c'était très faible
ou vraiment à peine.
Et je sentis presque durant la réunion
que j'étais en train d'auditionner pour être le fils de mon père.
Quand le livre sortit, je reçus des critiques justes dans les journaux
mais le journal à Luton n'est pas The Guardian,
c'est le Luton News,
et le titre à propos du livre était
« Le livre qui pourrait combler un fossé de 32 ans. »
Je compris que ça peut aussi symboliser
le fossé entre deux générations,
entre des gens comme moi et la génération de mon père,
il n'y a pas de tradition chez les Caribéens
de mémoires ou de biographies.
C'était une tradition de ne pas parler de tes affaires en public.
Mais j'accueillais ce titre, et je pensais qu'en fait, oui,
il y a une possibilité que
ça puisse ouvrir des conversations que nous n'avions jamais eues avant.
Ça pourrait, peut-être, combler le trou entre les générations.
Ça pourrait être un outil de réparation.
Et j'ai même commencé à penser
que ce livre pourrait être vu par mon père
comme un acte de dévouement filial.
Pauvre idiot bercé d'illusions.
Bageye fut piqué par ce qu'il perçut comme
le public mettant ses défauts sur le tapis.
Il fut piqué par ma trahison,
et il se rendit aux journaux le lendemain
demander un droit
de réponse et il l'eut avec le titre
« Bageye mord en retour ».
Et c'était un compte-rendu étincelant de ma trahison.
Je n'étais pas son fils.
Il reconnut intérieurement que ses couleurs
avaient été salies. Il ne pouvait pas le permettre.
Il devait restaurer sa dignité, il le fit,
et initialement, bien que j'aie été déçu,
je grandis pour admirer cette place.
Il y avait toujours du feu bouillonnant dans ses veines,
bien qu'il ait 82 ans.
Et si ça voulait dire qu'il reviendrait
à 30 ans de silence,
mon père dirait : « Si c'est comme ça, c'est comme ça. »
Les Jamaïcains vous diront que les faits n'existent pas,
qu'il n'y a que des versions.
Nous nous racontons tous des versions de l'histoire
avec lesquelles nous vivons mieux.
Chaque génération construit un édifice
qu'ils sont réticents, parfois incapables de démonter,
mais par l'écriture, ma version de l'histoire
commença à changer,
et se détacha de moi.
Je perdis la haine pour mon père.
Je ne voulais plus qu'il meure ni le tuer,
et je me sentais libre,
plus libre que je ne l'avais jamais été.
Et je me demande si cette liberté
pourrait lui être transmise.
Pendant cette réunion initiale,
je fus frappé par une idée que je n'avais
que très peu de photographies de moi enfant.
Cette photo est une photo de moi,
à 9 mois.
Dans la photo originelle,
je suis porté par mon père, Bageye,
mais lorsque mes parents se séparèrent,
ma mère l'excisa de tous les aspects de notre vie.
Elle prit une paire de ciseaux et le coupa de chaque photo,
et pendant des années, je me disais que la vérité de cette photo
était que tu étais seul,
tu es sans support.
Mais il y a une autre façon de voir cette photo.
C'est une photo qui a le potentiel d'une réunion,
une possibilité d'être réuni avec mon père
et dans mon désir d'être soutenu par mon père,
je le portais vers la lumière.
Pendant cette première réunion,
c'était très gênant et tendu.
Pour détendre l'atmosphère,
nous décidâmes d'aller marcher.
Et en marchant, je fus frappé,
j'étais redevenu l'enfant
même si j'étais maintenant plus imposant que mon père.
J'étais presque 30 cm plus grand que lui.
Il était toujours le grand homme,
et j'essayais de suivre ses pas.
Je réalisais qu'il marchait
comme s'il était toujours observé,
mais j'admirais sa marche.
Il marchait comme un homme
qui a perdu la finale de la coupe d'Angleterre de football,
montant les marches pour collecter sa médaille de condoléance.
Il y avait de la dignité dans la défaite.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)